nick fuentes says that he tried to board
a plane this week only to discover that
he was
on the no-fly list and later he
published a video
of himself talking to a southwest agent
i think the southwest who tells him
in the video that he can't fly with them
and he needs to talk to tsa about it
which seems to confirm or at least
provide good evidence that he is indeed
on some kind of no-fly lessons it's not
just
a matter of one airline saying you can't
board for this or that reason
um now anyone who who has listened to
this show for a while knows that nick
fuentes and i
have not seen eye to eye to put it
mildly but here's the thing you don't
have to see eye to eye with a person
you don't have to agree with them about
everything or anything at all in order
to be
very very troubled at the prospect the
possibility
that people are being put on a no-fly
list because of their political
viewpoints
their ideological viewpoints
i mean no matter it doesn't matter how
you feel about those views
nick fuentes hasn't been convicted of
any crime he hasn't been charged with
any crime
he was at the capitol on january 6 but
he says he was never in the building
never entered the building hasn't been
charged with entering it
now think about the no fly list is that
um you aren't gonna know exactly
why you're on it so you could say well
maybe there's a good reason
well so what we're supposed to just
trust
the government when they say that that's
the problem they don't tell you
why you're on it they don't even tell
you that you're on it
you have to go and try to fly like what
happened
in this case you have to try to get on a
plane and that's when you find out
and even then they won't tell you
everything
so for me this is kind of easy um
i i don't think i don't think the no-fly
should exist at all i don't think anyone
should be on it if the government can
prove that you're a dangerous criminal
they should convict you um
of of that crime and and punish you for
it
but if they can't prove it if they can't
even muster enough evidence to
charge you with a crime okay again this
is a punishment
no flyless is a punishment imposed on
people
not only before they've been convicted
of a crime
but before they've even been charged
with any crime or accused
of any crime the government can still
say you're not allowed to fly
we're not going to tell you why we're
not going to necessarily give you any
process to get off of it
with the no file list they can restrict
your movement without any burden of
proof just by they just bypass the bill
of rights entirely that's a problem
and it's a power begging to be abused
it's an abusive power by its own nature
and it and it can be abused further
and wielded as a political weapon which
perhaps now this is exactly what this
administration is doing
and it could happen anybody the
government nick foreign anybody
and if you're on the right which you
also have to keep in mind
is that the powers that be
democrats and leftists they don't draw
any distinction
between anybody on the right
they've got the category of the right
and everyone is the same
they don't draw any distinction between
any of them so anything you see
happening to one person in that category
can happen to everybody
whether they're being de-platformed
kicked off social media
put on no fly list
that could happen to everybody i mean
just think about think about if there
was uh
what if there was a no drive list think
about that because i
one of the excuses i've heard this in
relation to the nick fuentes thing
um even even even conservatives i i've
heard say
uh that well flying flying isn't a right
yeah it's not a constitutionally
guaranteed right but that doesn't mean
that the government can take it away
without any justification at all
is that what we're saying if a right is
not guaranteed and listed
in the bill of rights specifically then
the government can can take it away for
any reason without any justification
without any
uh uh accountability transparency is
that really the road we want to go down
and as far as going down roads yeah
imagine a no drive list driving also is
not a guaranteed right in the
constitution
um but what if you got
pulled over because you're like your
license plate was flagged
and the cop told you oh sorry you're on
a no drive list you're not allowed to
drive
you haven't been convicted you know you
haven't been convicted of a crime you
haven't been accused of a crime
you weren't drunk driving nothing like
that you just you got on a list
somehow maybe because of your political
views you've been you've been deemed
a threat for reasons that are unclear
and now they say you can't drive
and not only can you not drive you can't
even be a passenger
on the road we know there are people who
get their licenses
taken away but that's for a reason
there's a reason for it
and you have a process through the court
system to rectify it if a mistake was
made
or if you believe you're innocent or
whatever
would anyone accept that a no drive list
that functions that way then why do we
accept it with a no-fly list
and you can't say that oh flying is is
more dangerous so it's a different kind
of thing
it's not driving is a hell of a lot more
dangerous and a hell of a lot more
people die doing it
so they can do with with the planes they
do it with
cars do with any vehicle
why not well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content